the clark county school bus drivers are
getting a raise now the move comes after
a shortage of bus drivers during the
pandemic mary jane belliesa shares how
ccsd employees are hoping this will help
solve the problem
latrice mcallen has been a driver with
ccsd for four years she says it's a
passion to work with kids and says the
pay increase is a good way to recognize
the hard work bus drivers have to put in
every day it's going to benefit me in a
lot of ways the pay increase i'm a
single parent
gas is high
rent is going up so i'm very pleased
with the pay raise executive director of
transportation jennifer vovis says the
pay increase comes after an evaluation
with the district ccsd deemed
transportation employees to a higher pay
grade after reviewing job duties
responsibilities and performance
everybody's been very excited about it
i've heard a lot of anecdotal stories
i myself had a driver who
was put in their two weeks notice and
after the announcement was made they
rescinded their two weeks notice i've
heard drivers say that they now they can
quit their second job starting pays at
21.50 for bus drivers that's a six
dollar increase from before the district
hopes that all pay increases for all
positions will help with retention and
future hires currently there are 250 bus
driver vacancies daniel mack hayward has
been a driving instructor for 17 years
she's seen her fair share of people come
and go it's an incentive for the
instructors because now we can be more
competitive with other jobs so as people
come in they'll be willing to stay and
further their
opportunities in the district reporting
from weltman way and las vegas boulevard
mary jane balleza live local now